dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on AFA here this
piece of work is not meant to be a
highly useful application only a
tongue-in-cheek jab at the rising trend
of trying to solve simple problems using
deep learning without carefully
examining the problem at hand
as always we know that all intuitive
explanations are wrong but some are
helpful and the most precise way to
express these thoughts can be done by
using mathematics however we shall leave
that to the textbooks and will try to
understand these concepts by floating
about on the wings of intuition in
mathematics a matrix is a rectangular
array in which we can store numbers and
symbols matrices can be interpreted in
many ways for instance we can think of
them as transformations multiplying a
matrix with our vector means applying
this transform to the vector such as
scaling rotation or shearing the rank of
a matrix can be intuitively explained in
many ways my favorite intuition is that
the rank encodes the information content
of the matrix for instance in an earlier
work on separable subsurface scattering
we recognized that many of these
matrices that encode light scattering
inside translucent materials are of
relatively low rank this means that the
information within is highly structured
and it is not random noise and from this
lower rank property follows that we can
compress and represent this phenomenon
using simpler data structures leading to
an extremely efficient algorithm to
simulate light scattering within our
skin however the main point is that
finding out the rank of a large matrix
is an expensive operation it is also
important to note that we can also
visualize these matrices by mapping the
members within two different colors as a
fun side note the paper finds that the
uglier the color scheme is the better
suited it is for learning this way after
computing the ranks of many matrices we
can create a lot of input images and
output ranks for the neural network to
learn on after that the goal is that we
feed in an
matrix in the form of an image and the
network would have to guess what the
rank is it is almost like having an
expert scientist unleash his intuition
on such a matrix much like a fun
guessing game for intoxicated
mathematicians and the ultimate question
as always is how does this knowledge
learnt by the neural network generalize
the results are decent but not
spectacular but they also offer some
insights as to which matrices have
surprising ranks we can also try
computing the products of matrices which
intuitively translates to guessing the
result after we have done one
transformation after the other like the
output of scaling after a rotation
operation they also try to compute the
inverse of matrices for which the
intuition can be undoing the
transformation if it is a rotation to a
given direction the inverse would be
rotating back the exact same amount or
if we scaled something up then scaling
it back down would be its inverse of
course these are not the only operations
that we can do with matrices we only use
these for the sake of demonstration
the lead author states on his website
this paper shows that quote linear
algebra can be replaced with machine
learning and quote talk about being
funny and tongue-in-cheek also I have
linked a website of David in the
description box he has a lot of great
works and I am surely not doing him
justice by of all those great works
covering this one Rufus Fong Rufus
graduate of the prestigious muddy paws
university was the third author of the
paper overlooking the entirety of the
work and making sure that the quality of
the results is impeccable as future work
I would propose replacing the basic
mathematical operators such as addition
and multiplication by machine learning
except that it is already done and is
hilariously fun and it even supports
division by zero talk about the almighty
powers of deep learning thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and as
see you next time